the big story of the day and we've got a
quote from reuters billionaire elon musk
offers to buy twitter for 41.39
billion dollars a regulatory filing
shows okay so this is this is pretty
powerful stuff now if you were paying
attention for the last two weeks you may
remember that uh about a week and a half
ago or so he bought this first 9.2
of twitter which made him the largest
stakeholder in twitter uh but he was not
obviously a majority shareholder right
he didn't own over 50 of it but he was
the largest individual stakeholder then
he said he was going to get on the board
they offered him a seat they had a
couple tweets going back and forth
between him and the the ceo of twitter
and the former ceo of twitter and all
that and everybody's playing nice but
then of course the the woke activists
that are in the company because they've
been eating this company alive much like
disney's employees are eating disney
alive and all of these companies are
being eaten alive by activist employees
who should have no right to direct a
company you're an employee you get a
check do your job go home get a life
then it started getting weird so elon
musk said he wasn't going to take the
board seat because if he had taken
the board seat that would have kept him
at about 14 and a half percent that's
just the way the rules work and he would
have never been able to do a hostile
takeover meaning just take over the
whole freaking company so a few days ago
that's what he said i'm not taking the
board seat actually twitter at 11 p.m on
sunday night announced that he wasn't
taking the board seat and it led to this
and it is freaking beautiful here is the
letter from elon musk to brett taylor
the chairman of the board
at twitter
from elon i invested in twitter as i
believe in its potential to be the
platform for free speech around the
globe and i believe free speech is a
societal imperative for a functioning
democracy however since making my
investment i now realize the company
will neither thrive nor serve the
societal imperative in its current form
twitter needs to be transformed as a
private company as a result i am
offering to buy
100 percent of twitter for
54.20 per share in cash my offer is my
best and final offer and if it is not
accepted i would need to reconsider my
position as shareholder twitter has
extraordinary potential
i will unlock it elon musk can you guys
let me know the the shares of twitter
what are they worth right now because
he's paying a massive premium on those
shares i am sure they are worth much
less than that 50 plus dollars there
yeah they're worth right now twitter's
shares is this as of this morning
because i would love to know what they
were even yesterday if they jumped so
right now twitter's shares are
46.47 a share so he's tacking on about
six dollars a share okay
that's yesterday's oh and yesterday it
was 45-44 so it went up because of elan
okay you understand what's going on here
and he is saying i will pay another
roughly six dollars per share just to
take the whole freaking thing right now
so there is a massive war brewing and
just understand and this is why i wanted
to do this as the theme of the show we
have watched the woke monster destroy
everything we have allowed companies
like twitter like disney uh all of these
companies the list goes on and on right
we have watched all the commercials you
watch just absolutely everything we have
watched all of these companies push
their woke ideology on us we have
watched them censor us we have watched
them ban people they have allowed us to
say what you can say and what you can't
say who can say what when they can say
it all of it and here's one guy now he's
a pretty extraordinary guy right he's
the he's the iron man of our time
right
but he's just one man and he's saying i
am putting my money where my mouth is
think of the freaking headaches that
this is gonna cause for elon musk right
like this is a guy he could literally be
like you know what i've just had about
enough of earth i'm getting on my own
rocket ship that will be the most
mind-blowing freaking thing ever and i'm
gonna spend the rest of my life going to
mars and then i'm going to build a
colony on mars and i'm going to have my
own planet that's what he could do and
that would actually be pretty cool and
maybe he will do that but instead he
said i'm going to put 50 freaking
billion dollars
is that the number is it 50 50 billion
total what's the total number 100 of
twitter what's the actual number that
he's going to put down here it's it's
incredible it doesn't even matter what
the number is we'll get the oh yeah
41.39 billion dollars i'm gonna put it
doesn't even matter whether he has a
gajillion dollars or not but he's saying
i will do something there is a problem
we all know there's a problem and i will
do something and this is how you
freaking fight back
i happen to write a book about